.
YOU WANT TO CAMPAIGN IN MIDDLE
AMERICA, YOU BETTER STAND FOR
MIDDLE AMERICA.
JOINING ME AS BOB LIGHTHIZER,
FORMER TRUMP TRADE
REPRESENTATIVE.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WHAT'S THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH
THIS REIMAGINED TPP?
>> LET ME SAY FIRST OF ALL, TO
YOUR OTHER POINT, THE BROADER
POINT.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AS THE
PARTY OF WORKING PEOPLE, PERIOD
RIGHT NOW.
BIG BUSINESS IS WITH THE
DEMOCRATS.
TECH IS WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
THE QUESTION THAT YOU SAVE
YOURSELF, WHAT CAN WE DO FOR
WORKING-CLASS PEOPLE THAT WILL
CREATE MORE JOBS AND RAISE WAGES
FOR THESE PEOPLE.
YOU'VE GOT THREE THINGS THAT A
SENSIBLE REPUBLICAN CAN DO.
ONE, CUT TAXES.
THAT WILL HELP JOBS.
CUT TAXES ON BUSINESS.
NOT NECESSARILY ON INDIVIDUALS.
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE DON'T SEE
THAT IS IN THEIR INTEREST.
YOU CAN CUT REGULATIONS WHICH IS
ALSO SENSIBLE AND HELPFUL.
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE DON'T SEE
THAT IS IN THEIR INTEREST
EITHER.
AND THEN YOU CAN DO SOMETHING ON
TRADE.
YOU CAN FIGHT FOR OUR JOBS.
YOU CAN FIGHT FOR A BALANCED
TRADE, FIGHT FOR FAIR TRADE.
WORKING-CLASS PEOPLE SEE THE
BENEFIT OF THAT SO TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AS A REPUBLICAN AND
NOT EMBRACE THIS NEW AMERICA
FIRST APPROACH ON TRADE IS IN MY
JUDGMENT SUICIDE.
YOU WILL LOSE OHIO WHERE I AM
FRONT AND YOU WILL LOSE
PENNSYLVANIA AND A LOT OF THESE
OTHER PLACES.
IF WE BECOME THE PARTY OF THE
U.S. CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND BIG
BUSINESS IN THIS FIELD, IT'S A
MISTAKE.
SECONDLY ON YOUR QUESTION OF THE
TPP, THE TPP WAS A DISASTER FROM
THE BEGINNING.
IT WAS NEVER EVER GOING TO
INCREASE EXPORTS.
IT WAS ALSO TALK ALWAYS ABOUT
IMPORTS.
THE NOTION THAT IT'S SOMEHOW
ENCIRCLING CHINA IS CRAZY
NOTION.
THE REALITY IS THE WAY THAT
THING WAS WRITTEN, THE WAY IT
WAS WRITTEN, YOU COULD INCREASE
SHIPMENTS, PARTS OF PRODUCTS
COULD COME FROM CHINA IN THE
UNITED STATES, GET DUTY-FREE
TREATMENT THAT THEY CAN'T GET
NOW.
WE REALLY --
IT WAS THE BIGGEST SINGLE GIFT
TO CHINA.
IT WAS A CRAZY NOTION.
I ASKED PEOPLE SPECIFICALLY,
TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK WE ARE
GOING TO EXPERT AS A -- EXPORT
AS A RESULT OF THIS AGREEMENT.
NOBODY CAN GIVE ME ANYTHING OF
ANY CONSEQUENCE.
THE PRINCIPAL BENEFIT.
WHEN THEY FIRST SOLD, THE
PRINCIPAL BENEFIT WAS
AGRICULTURAL SALES TO JAPAN.
WE GOT THOSE IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IN THE U.S.-JAPAN
DEAL.
WE GOT ALL BENEFIT YOU CAN GET
OUT OF IT.
NOW IT'S JUST GOING TO HURT US
AND IT CAN'T BE FIXED.
IT LITERALLY IS LIKE PUTTING
LIPSTICK ON A PIG.
IT CANNOT BE FIXED.
>> Laura: BOB, THIS ISSUE OF
STEEL TARIFFS, THE WTO NOT
SURPRISINGLY, THE WORLD TRADE
ORGANIZATION, HAS RULED AGAINST
AMERICAN STEEL TARIFFS THAT WERE
PUT IN PLACE BY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SAYING THEIR
UNFAIRLY PROTECTIONIST AND THEY
PUT OTHER COUNTRIES AT A
DISADVANTAGE.
BOB, WITH EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE
DONE IN YOUR ENTIRE CAREER ON
TRADE.
BOB IS THE MOST BRILLIANT PERSON
ON TRADE FRANKLY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
ON THE ISSUE STEEL, WHAT HAS
HAPPENED TO OUR STEEL INDUSTRY
AND THE GREAT GLOBALIZATION.
>> WELL, THE REALITY IS THE
STEEL INDUSTRY IN THE
UNITED STATES HAS BEEN
DECIMATED.
PERIOD OF DECADES BUT IT'S BEEN
AROUND THE WORLD TOO.
THERE IS MORE EXCESS CAPACITY IN
STEEL, NONECONOMIC EXCESS
CAPACITY AND STEEL IN CHINA THAN
THERE IS PRODUCTION IN PLACES
LIKE THE UNITED STATES, EUROPE,
JAPAN.
SO WE NEED THOSE TARIFFS.
THE WTO CASE WAS OUTRAGEOUS BUT
NOT SURPRISING.
WE MADE A CLEAR DECISION THAT
EVERY COUNTRY MAKES ITS OWN
DECISION ON NATIONAL SECURITY.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING WHERE YOU
HAVE THESE THREE WISE MEN AND
THEY ARE NOT THE WISE MEN THAT
FOUND CHRISTMAS BY THE WAY,
THESE ARE NOT WISE MEN WHO
DIDN'T FIND CHRISTMAS.
SO THE NOTION THAT YOU HAVE AN
ARBITRATION, THREE PEOPLE, THREE
BUREAUCRATS IN BRUSSELS,
DECIDING WHAT'S IN AMERICA'S
NATIONAL INTEREST IS COMPLETELY